Okay, so let's see the ROB quiz solution. So we do need the ROB to.
Remember the program order. That's the only place where the program order is
preserved between the issue which is done in program order, and the commit which
is also done in program order because things in between are done out of order.
So, we definitely need the ROB for that. To temporarily store the instructions
result, yes. The ROB holds the instruction's result between the time when it is
produced, meaning when we're actually broadcasting it on the bus.
And the time when the instruction's result is committed to the register file, so
we definitely have that role for the ROB. To service the name or the TAG for
the result. Yes. With [UNKNOWN] algorithm the reservation station was playing
this role bit with the ROB, the ROB entry is really going to serve this role for
an instruction. To store the source operands, until dispatch,
know the reservation's station still. Will retain this role, basically
the reservation station still stores the source operand until dispatch, so
this answer is not correct. And to determine which instruction goes to which
execution unit, again ROB doesn't play this role, the rob is usually unified
meaning all of the instructions go to the same ROB, they just get different
entries in it. We know which execution unit instructions should go to because,
different execution units have different reservation stations. So, when we
issue an instruction we send it to the right set of reservation stations and
that determines what is going to be the execution unit.
So, this answer is also not correct.